哈囉大家好 歡迎
來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天一樣來到了
10分鐘心理學
我發現這個主題
大家真的很喜歡
然後有的時候偶爾
我在槌兒會被推播到
就是有些人會提到說
這一次的10分鐘心理學對
他的幫助是什麼
我覺得非常開心
感謝大家對我們中
不知放心說的支持
今天10分鐘心理學要
跟大家討論的這個主題
就是我們最近
常常講的MBTI
但是又跟MBTI
有一些差別的是
上台一人下台哀人
假我如何讓我們離真實的
自己越來越遠
等一下老師你這樣的意思是
上台一人下台哀人不好嗎
不是的 我說的是如果這一
件事情對你來說
每一次都是一個眼
每一次都很用力的時候
他對你的影響是什麼
怎麼說上台一人下台哀人
其實有很多就是我們遇到
不管是Youtuber
也好 演員也好
或者甚至是一些主持人也好
他們可能都有這樣的狀態
那就是上台的時候
講得非常好
而且看起來很有自信
要跟誰打招呼
聊天都非常非常容易
因此你會覺得
他也太會社交了
他的就是跟別人討論 聊天
還有他的口條也太好了
但是平常他下台
還有他的日常生活中
可能大部分都是
把自己關起來
看書 不說話
或是不想社交
也就是一個哀人
所以有些人會說
這個好像是一個
好事和上台的狀況
可是這個狀況
他不僅僅是一個性格的問題
他可能是因為我們有個假
我在發揮作用
講到這個上台 依
人 下台 哀人
其實滿有趣的是
我在一些節目曾經有分享過
對我來說
工作上最喜歡跟
最輕鬆的工作
不能說最輕鬆
應該是說我最不會覺得
我很耗能 很耗能的工作
其實是在做諮商的時候
但是我大部分會
比較需要比較用力
然後必須要就是
讓自己準備好
現在我是周木之心理師
於是要做一個像上台的感覺
就比較像我盧帕克斯的演示
或是去演講
甚至是去上一些節目等等
因為在這個過程中
我一直以為我就是一個依人
在很多很多時候
我做測驗依人的
成績幾乎是滿分的
那我有分享過
我去跟雪莉老師
做測驗的時候
因為她會問我一些問題
我才發現原來我是個哀人
只是我在依人的
面向被訓練得太好
我就開始思考一件事情
為什麼我會成為一個看起來
這麼一的依人
我是一個在上台
還有做什麼事情
我幾乎都不會覺得緊張
然後非常清楚我在那個時候
要做什麼事跟說什麼話的人
為什麼呢
我後來發現
這個也是我今天
要跟大家分享的
為什麼會上台依人
有的時候如果你不是真的依
你是上台的時候很依
但下台你看起來
是另外一個樣子
他很有可能是因為
這一個依外向的情況
他其實是一個被
社會獎勵的表現模式
我們之前在跟雪莉老師
聊到MVTI的時候
其實有討論到依人其實是
一個社會比較鼓勵的
就是你要講自己的意見
要表達自己
都是一個比較大方的
比較願意做的
可以自信 熱情 和群
這個樣子比較容易被喜歡
而在我們台灣社會裡
可以做到這樣的事情的人
其實是很容易可能會得到
比較多的資源
也會得到權威比較多的肯定
然後也不會被
人家覺得說好像
什麼陰陽怪氣
邊緣人啊
或者是被不喜歡啊等等
因此依人這件事情
他其實很容易被肯定
但話說回來
在台灣社會
當依人還是有一些風險的
也就是你太一的話會怎麼樣
也會被討厭喔
所以台灣喜歡什麼
就是你有需要
的時候才當依人
也就是你在某些時候
我需要你提供依人的功能
但是平常
你看起來要是個哀人
所以我在猜喔
這也就是為什麼
台灣有很多
看起來非常擅長
跟別人相處的人
結果人家就會說
最後他都會說
喔他好像是個哀人之類的
這可能跟我們的
一些文化的需求
還有我們從小被訓練的方式
的確是有關係的
那麼我為什麼會說
做這件事情
因為被社會獎勵
他可能跟我們的夾我有關呢
我在停止內耗這堂課
有提到夾我這個概念
夾我的意思其實是
當你在環境中
還要求你壓抑真實的反應
並且呢
希望你去迎合
外界期待的時候
你會創造出一個
看起來剛好適合的一個自己
也就是生存策略
某方面來說
你可以把它想像成
你有一個真實的自我
可是這個真實自我呢
這個社會他不滿意
你的父母
你的老師
你的身邊的人
他期待你可以更像什麼樣子
才可以被肯定被喜歡
也有可能他們
不一定是要求你
但他們可能會去說
唉呦你看那個某某啊
他這樣子真是不錯
於是你開始學會
這樣可以得到比較多的資源
跟得到比較多的肯定
於是呢
你開始發展出一套
你自己的投影機
這一套投影機呢
會從把這個真實的你
投影的比較漂亮
比較被喜歡
比較好看
然後呢
你就把它訓練跟
投影出來之後呢
這個訓練出來的夾我
被肯定之後
你就會回去再升級
你的投影機
那大家聽了就覺得說
哎
可是這樣也還不錯啊
老師那我們就有投影機
我覺得沒有錯
你可以說
因為榮格會講是人格面具
精神分析
問尼考特說
這個是夾我
他有很多很多形容的東西
這個部分
他不好嗎
不能說完全不好
因為你有的時候
就必須要有這個面具在嘛
比如說你身為一個醫生
你當一個醫生什麼樣子
他就比較容易
可以被病人接受
你如果看起來就是
就是穿了一個
很奇怪的衣服
然後呢
看起來講話就
就是拽拽的
然後講話又很不專業的話
這個病人就會覺得
這個醫生講話是真的嘛
之類的
當然每一個工作
會有他自己的面具在
可是我們剛剛講的這個夾我
跟這個投影機
最麻煩的地方是
如果今天我們
訓練出這個面具
或訓練出這個投影機
就是為了被肯定
就是為了被接納
當我今天因為
訓練出這個夾我
被接納之後
會怎麼樣
我們就覺得
很讚對不對
那你接下來會花時間
認識的會是你真實的自己
還是你會去升級那個投影機
你會去升級讓這一個
偶像包袱
讓這個面具
讓這個投影機
變得越漂亮越好看
看起來如果你
看起來是專業的
就看起來要越專業
看起來是一個就是
正直的人就看起來要越正直
可是他可能
他可能離真實的自己
是有一段距離的
並不代表你是個不正直的人
而是說你還是會有很多
想要照顧自己
保護自己的時候
你不會永遠都是
很有爭議感的
可是為了要讓你自己
得到更多社會的肯定
還有社會的接納
於是你會花更多的時間
去發展這個投影機的時候
你就會離真實的
自己越來越遠
所以回到這個狀態
我反而覺得下台挨人
是一件滿好的事情
什麼事
那就是我自己其實很清楚
我上台一人這件事情
是個面具
是個投影機
是個符合社會需求
或是符合這個工作
倫理的一個樣子
但是我下台之後
我有我自己的需要
我有自己的感受
我有真實的自己要照顧
因此我一下台
一下課
一下班
我會需要自己的空間
我會需要喘息
我會需要讓自己喘口氣
做我自己想做的事情
而沒有任何的評價
不用擔心這樣做
會不會影響到別人
或或者是會不會不太好
講到這件事情很有趣
我說我以前一直
覺得我是個一人
不過當學藝老師
他在提到說我是個哀人
但是是被訓練得
非常好的時候
我都突然想到
一件非常有趣的事
就是我在大學跟
研究所的時候
都是那種
比如說早上要一起上課
下午也要一起上課
中午的吃飯時間
我絕對保證
一定要自己買飯
回宿舍
自己一個人吃
我那時候住的是兩人宿舍
我的另外一個室友
是比較可以跟大家一起互動
跟社交的人
所以我就是堅持不管任何
就是旁邊的人怎麼說
我們一起去吃飯啊
大家一起去為什麼不去
我都堅持我一定要
買飯自己一個人
然後回宿舍
就是休息那一個小時
在那個時候我朋友
同學都會開玩笑
我說中午是你很孤僻
你為什麼要這個樣子
但是我跟大家相處的時候
又好像看起來很開心
很熱情的樣子
我就說我跟大家
的緣分已經盡了
下午再聚
我那時候不知道為什麼
自己一定要這樣
後來我發現對我來說
要去就是消化很多
在社交的時候
很多人的訊息
我要馬上去
非常快速的去看大家的反應
然後要去做處理
或是去決定我現在
應該要什麼樣子
怎麼去跟大家互動
其實對我來說
是一件很耗力的事情
因此我覺得
當你自己能夠對自己
有更多的理解的時候
你對自己的選擇
跟空間其實會比較多
你就不用讓自己
一直長期的帶著面具
而這個上台一人下台
挨人的狀況
其實會得到一個
比較大的空間
跟調和
在這裡可能會有些人
就會想問一個問題
老師你這樣講
假我跟真我
我還是不太懂
那這樣子假我就是假的
真我就是真的嗎
那假我就是不好的
我覺得應該是這樣講
假我比較像是
就是我們剛剛說的面具
你會比較清楚
在什麼時候我要是什麼樣子
會比較好
或者是
我其實也有很懶惰
很想要打混的時候
可是我知道
我需要變得比較有功能
在一些工作上才會比較好
大家會對我比較安心
我也可以得到一些權利
所以某方面來說
假我是一個選擇
可是如果你沒有很清楚
你做這個選擇是為了什麼
他會把全部的你都吞噬
甚至你有時候也需要休息
也需要放鬆的時候
你還是用這個假我在工作
你就會變得很辛苦
我舉一個我最常見的例子
那就是我聽過很多人就會說
他平常就算休息的時候
他都沒辦法休息
他都必須要想說
他要去上什麼課做什麼事
然後把很多事情做得很好
因為他會擔心他休息的話
他就會有罪惡感
這就是假我把你的
日常生活的真我
也整個吃掉的
一個很重要的例子
在我們玩行裡面
常常會說就是
你在某一個部分的
一個個性特質變得非常的強
然後你的自我
還有你的其他的特質
也全部都被吃掉
甚至被壓抑住
這會引發我們很多的情緒
而所謂這些被壓抑住的東西
融格有時候會
把它說成是陰影
然後玩行就會說
這是兩級的情緒
兩級的特質
其中一個特質就是在比較
就是被壓抑的部分
而如果我們用假
我跟真我來看
這個部分就比較像是真我
也就是說在那個當下
你有一個自發性
想要展現跟想要回應
當下的情緒不壓抑不能
不壓抑不忍耐
不假裝的那個部分
當他因為你太
肯定假我的時候
他被壓抑的時候
他被否定的時候
他常常不允許出來的時候
我們人就會開始
變得很不平衡
所以當我們今天可以選擇
下台挨人的時候
其實是一種很
重要的自我修復
所以這時候我們
就可以理解到
假我其實是一個
我們社會適應的方式
某方面他就是一個社會化
也就是說你從小到大
你知道當一個社會化的人
你該怎麼做
你要說什麼話
做什麼事
這就是假我對
我們最大的功誘
因此他具有情緒防衛
也有社會適應的狀況
那就是如果今天
我表現得很好
我就會被接納
我就會被喜歡
我今天表現得很開朗
大家就會比較
喜歡跟我做朋友
這件事情其實是假
我很重要的功能
所以你也不能說假我
就是很不好的地方
但可能有些人會有些問題
那就是老師那我要怎麼知道
我現在只是有一個人格面具
我知道什麼時候該做什麼事
還是這個東西
他已經佔據了我的生活
甚至讓我沒有辦法
認識真實的自己呢
我會用幾個部分讓大家瞭解
稍微檢視一下
你的假我有沒有
造成你生活的影響
首先第一點
那就是你的情緒延遲反應
或是情緒格決
也就是說你可能出現比較多
好像跟你的情緒
有一些距離的狀況
例如你可能
譬如說工作一整天
看起來就是非常好相處
然後大家就覺得
你是好好先生
好好小姐
回去你就開始變得很暴躁
很不耐煩
看誰都不順眼
特別想要就是罵家人
或是罵伴侶幾下
情緒或是自己在家裡
突然情緒崩潰
覺得我不能吃一桶炸雞
我就是要吃兩桶
炸雞這一類的
這個部分就是
一個非常常見的
也許你在就是工作
或是日常生活中
你承擔了太多
也許離你自己真實感受
比較遠的東西
但是你必須要表現出
另外一個情緒的樣子
這也就是假我的一部分
第二個就是我開始有一些
角色認同的混亂
比如說我是誰
例如我不知道我
到底是在演自己
還是這是真的我
這是我自己真實的一部分
甚至我覺得我好假
我覺得我很空虛
我講一個最常出現的狀況
那就是我因為很
害怕真實的自己
例如說有一些人非常強力的
太脆弱了會被否定
因為他不符合
社會的主流價值
就是類似像護家盟
因此我很長的一段時間
或是他們就覺得說
必須要扮演另外一個人
而這個人會讓我覺得安全
因為可以讓真實的我遠一點
然後有一些男性
這也是夾我一個
非常重要的功能
他很嚴重的恐同症
如果我很討厭自己
結果最後過了多年之後
我就可以扮演
他自己承認
我想要成為的那個自己
這一類的
然後但是做
這件事情的過程中
我反而會更討厭
我真實的自己
因此如果你常常
需要做這件事情
你是不是會出現
很多的社交疲勞
跟自我懷疑呢
絕對的
因為你越努力維持你的形象
你越會覺得現在大家喜歡我
是為什麼
是因為我現在是這個樣子
你們才會喜歡我嗎
如果我很沒用
如果我表現出我真正的樣子
如果我脾氣很差
如果我怎麼樣
你們一定就不喜歡我
所以真正的我越不會被認同
可是這件事情有一個矛盾點
那就是你表現出來了你
跟你內在真實的自己
它可能都是你
可是因為你只選了
你認為大家會
覺得正向的自己
把它表現出來
你內在的那些需求
跟被壓抑的東西
就一定要用最負面
跟最不能被接受
的方式去處理
這是絕對的
因為這就是因應
帶給我們最大的困難跟
跟困難跟我們
情緒的一些能量
紓解的一種功用
你某方面也可以把它說功用
因為它就是為了平衡我們
所以當我們今天越能接受
真正的我是什麼樣子的時候
我其實越不用用
那麼用力的方式
去維持那個最好
最誇張 最完美的樣子
我其實真正的自己
它有可能有時候可以很正直
它可能有的時候
會很保護自己
有些人會覺得我很自私
可是這些都是我
我有一些我自己的準則
我有一些我自己的理由
這就是真實的我會做的事情
當你越能夠讓你爭我跟假我
獲得一個平衡的時候
其實你會發現
你人生的準則是什麼
你是一個什麼樣的人
你其實會越清楚
所以最後
我就是要來教大家這件事情
怎麼靠近真實自我呢
首先很鼓勵大家
練習辨認你的假我語言
當你說我應該
我不能讓人失望的時候
這很有可能就是你的人格
面具你的假我再說話
因為他希望你可以符合
這個社會的需求
另外
讓你自己可以允許
真實自我有一些真實的情緒
所以有些情緒
即使你覺得不社會化
你覺得不應該回答
不應該存在
也讓自己看到它
然後不要做任何評論
比如說
我看到別人表現得比我好
我就是會覺得嫉妒
我今天工作得很累
雖然我知道這件事情
大家都覺得很開心
很好很棒
可是我就是覺得
好煩喔
我想要休息了
對不起
我知道有些人工作
就是可以做多少個小時
很認真
但我個人就是
我就是草莓族
我只能做幾個小時
能夠讓你自己幫助接受
你現在出現的情緒
沒有任何的評論
而是好好的接納
你的真我能夠越穩定
其實你的假我
就越不用讓你
扮演得這麼用力
另外呢
非行鼓勵
如果有時候你的工作的特性
比如說像Youtuber
或者是說你有需要
常常有一些偶像包袱
要扮演
有一些人設
請你自己能夠幫自己設定
定期下台的時間
可以不用扮演誰
也可以不用被誰看見
我自己個人自我的時間
其實是非常非常長的
而某方面來說
在我這段時間裡面
我也很努力的開始
慢慢再整合我自己
希望我可以不用在日常生活
扮演周木茲心理
師這個人的時候
需要做的事情
離真實的自我太遠
我也不要讓周木茲心理師
把周木茲這個人給吃掉
因為心理師
只是我其中的一個工作
這也就是我努力
讓我自己的假我跟真我
能夠有一些
比較好的平衡的一個方式
所以最後提醒一下大家
上台一人 下台哀人
這件事情沒有任何問題
我們都在用我們自己的方式
在找屬於自己的平衡
我們的角色
我們的面具
可以切換 可以選擇
但永遠記得一件事
你的選擇權在你身上
而任何一個角色
任何一個身份
不管他多巨大
他都不能代表你
你自己才能定義你自己
到底是什麼樣子
不要那麼快
當別人期待你是
什麼樣子的時候
你就想要做進去
因為我們的人生
最重要的功課
其實是決定
我自己的人生
想要過什麼樣
而我想要成為怎麼樣的自己
跟大家分享
希望大家喜歡
我們今天的主題
另外對假我有興趣的部分
或是對停止內耗的堂課
有興趣的朋友
我們一樣把連結放在資訊欄
有興趣的朋友可以再去看看
那麼 周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉 拜拜